[Música]
buenas tardes
la banca es quizás uno de los negocios
más antiguos de la humanidad
existen registros en india siria y
sumeria que datan de 2000 años antes de
cristo donde banqueros prestaban granos
agricultores comerciantes para que
movieran sus productos entre las
ciudades
durante miles de años la banca se dedicó
al negocio tradicional de intermediación
financiera y de venta de seguros las
grandes innovaciones surgieron en la
historia reciente
veamos 1950 nacen las primeras tarjetas
de crédito
en 1969 que microbank instaló los
primeros cajeros automáticos en nueva
york'
y en 1995 aparecen los primeros sistemas
de home banking que eran aplicaciones
que había que instalar en las pcs y se
conectaban a internet por medio de ésta
el lab
luego de esto algo sucedió
en 1996 empresas como charles schwab
vieron sus negocios amenazados por
empresas como it right' que solamente
existían en el ciberespacio y que
ofrecían exactamente el mismo producto a
una décima parte del costo
luego 1998 nace paypal uno de los
grandes precursores del comercio
electrónico donde ofrece seguridad en
transacciones en línea desde esa época
sin embargo
luego de los eventos del 11 de
septiembre y sobre todo después de la
crisis del 2008 lamentablemente la
innovación dejó de estar en la lista de
prioridades de los banqueros
qué es una empresa fintech si buscamos
en google vamos a encontrar una gran
cantidad de definiciones sin embargo en
términos sencillos una empresa fintech
es una empresa que desarrolla
herramientas tecnológicas para el sector
financiero
y por qué se llama la revolución fintech
si siempre han existido empresas
tecnológicas que le dan servicio a los
bancos la razón es muy sencilla es
porque nunca antes estas empresas habían
creado tales cambios en los modelos de
negocios de los bancos desde pagos por
telefonía móvil asistentes virtuales
billeteras electrónicas peer-to-peer
landing o desintermediación de la banca
y crowdfunding para financiamiento de
proyectos
todas estas empresas están generando
cambios importantes en los modelos de
negocios de los bancos los cuales están
teniendo que reinventarse y algunos lo
están haciendo con mucho éxito pero
otros lamentablemente no entonces
debemos de aprender de las lecciones del
pasado y entender qué es lo que ha
pasado en otras industrias
blackberry uno de los grandes jugadores
dominantes no supo reinventarse ante
apple y todos conocemos el desenlace de
esta historia blockbuster tampoco supo
reinventarse ante los servicios de
streaming de netflix iván sandoval
tampoco supo reinventarse ante amazon
creen ustedes que como estos ejemplos
sucedieron en eeuu si no fueron no
sucedió aquí en costa rica de nuestros
países
estamos exentos yo diría que
definitivamente no en costa rica hoy día
existen 1.600.000 iphones existen más de
190 mil suscriptores de netflix que
están acabando con las pulperías que
alquilan dividís y vídeos
y basta con ir a una librería
internacional y contar cuánta gente hay
adentro
citibank estima que en los próximos 10
años el 30 por ciento de los puestos de
trabajo que existen hoy en día en los
bancos no va a existir van a desaparecer
y hay algunos expertos que dicen que ese
porcentaje llegará hasta un 50 por
ciento si estas predicciones son ciertas
eso lo que significa es que dentro de 10
años 1 de cada 2 personas de los que
estamos hoy aquí sentados no va a tener
trabajo
pero esto se pone todavía más
interesante
cuantos banqueros todavía asignan
partidas presupuestarias a compras de
cajeros automáticos acabamos de ver una
gráfica sobre la el dinero en costa rica
es increíble que con el dinero tendiendo
a desaparecer todavía existan compras de
dispositivos que dispensan
efectivo cuantos banqueros siguen
asignando presupuestos para la apertura
de sucursales o cuantos han cerrado
conscientemente sucursales pero no para
ahorrar costos sino para tener más
recursos para invertir en tecnología y
acercarse más a los clientes
cuantos banqueros todavía contratan call
center para vender tarjetas de crédito
para dar servicio cliente o para vender
seguros autoexpedibles
cuando yo trabajaba en la banca
tradicional siempre existían dos
personas que eran los más importantes en
un banco eran las prima donnas eran el
gerente banca empresas y el gerente
banca personas y eran los que competían
entre sí para ver quién entra llaman
negocios al banco quién crecía más y
quién hacía más negocios si me preguntan
a mí hoy día si estas personas siguen
siendo todavía los más importantes mi
respuesta es rotundamente no la persona
más importante en un banco y los
banqueros lamentablemente pocos se han
dado cuenta de esto es el sitio es el
gerente de los bancos de hoy no son los
mismos bancos que eran hace 10 o 20 años
los bancos de hoy son empresas de
software cuyo producto es la banca y el
sitio es la persona que le va a ayudar a
ese banquero a definir si hay que
comprar más tarde o si se suben a la
nube
si invertir en seguridad o cuánto
invertir en seguridad
qué es blogging y si vale la pena subir
a blogs en iguales transacciones
si desarrolla el móvil o desarrollar web
cuál es la mejor forma de atraer nuevos
clientes y atender a esos nuevos
clientes
y finalmente si trabajar como trabajar o
inclusive si adquirir empresas fintech
hace algunas semanas estuve en un
seminario de visas donde uno de los
principales conferencistas le dio un
mensaje que se me quedó grabado a los
banqueros tradicionales que estaban ahí
y decía go cats son rivers mentoring y
el mensaje era consigas a uno de estos
muchachos trabaje con ellos entiendan
cómo interactúan entre ellos como inter
interactúan con la tecnología
pregúntenle qué opinan de un banco los
resultados van a ser increíblemente
reveladores este año en mi empresa
tuvimos la suerte de tener a cinco
muchachos que trabajaron con nosotros
durante sus vacaciones y que venían de
toronto de boston de atlanta y de
cartago los aportes de estos muchachos
han sido realmente impresionantes les
recomiendo tener esta experiencia
en el 2018 el año pasado concluyó un
estudio que tardó tres años en
realizarse que se llama de milenio el
destrucción index es un estudio que
llevó a cabo durante tres años se
hicieron entrevistas a 10.000
millennials y estos 10.000 milenios
estarán distribuidos en 75 compañías de
13 industrias 15 industrias diferentes
los millenials son muchachos que
nacieron entre 1981 y el año 2000 y en
costa rica representan el 25 por ciento
de nuestra problemas de nuestra
población
y estos son algunos de los resultados de
este estudio
uno de cada tres muchachos dicen que
estás dispuestos a cambiar de banco en
los próximos 90 días 53% de estos
muchachos dicen opinan que todos los
bancos son exactamente iguales y que no
les ofrecen nada diferente
73% de estos muchachos dicen que
prefieren llevar a cabo las
transacciones monetarias con empresas
como amazon google popey pal square en
vez de con un banco y finalmente
el 71% de estos muchachos increíblemente
prefieren ir a sentarse a la silla de un
dentista que ir a un banco
conocen ustedes new bank bank es el
primer unicornio de latinoamérica es un
banco
que fue fundado hace apenas seis años
que hoy día tiene 1500 empleados
que ha levantado un financiamiento de
820 millones de dólares que tiene 12
millones de clientes y que tiene una
valoración de 10 millones de dólares son
unicornios una empresa que al caso
alcanza una valoración de un millón de
dólares
david él es el fundador de new bank
es muchacho que vivió en costa rica
desde padres colombianos y se fue a
fundar su banco a brasil ni siquiera se
fue a colombia donde su familia se fue a
brasil y el motivo principal es la
escalabilidad
para nosotros alcanzar en nuestros
países una escala de 12 millones de
clientes es una tarea realmente difícil
y sin embargo no lo ha logrado en poco
tiempo sin una sola sucursal y usando
únicamente la tecnología pero entonces
la pregunta que yo hago es vamos qué
vamos a hacer en nuestros países vamos a
quedarnos de brazos cruzados esperando a
que lleguen estos gigantes tecnológicos
que vamos a hacer al respecto
los bancos tienen que aprender
de las lecciones de otras industrias
tienen que aprender de black the black
black berry de blockbusters de brandsen
nuevo las empresas fintech pueden darle
a los bancos las herramientas que
necesitan la innovación que necesitan
pero sobre todo la rapidez para llegar
al mercado porque hoy en día ni siquiera
la tecnología es un elemento
diferenciador la tecnología la puede
copiar cualquiera lo más importante es
el time to market llegar de primero al
mercado
si no me creen vean esta imagen donde
muestra cuánto tiempo le tardo a cada
una de estas industrias llegar a una
masa crítica de 50 millones de usuarios
empezando por la aviación que tardó 68
años siguiendo por la industria de
automóviles 62 la electricidad 46
cajeros automáticos 18 años en alcanzar
50 millones de usuarios la computación
tanto 14 el ipad 4 youtube 4 facebook 43
twitter 2 pokemon go 19 días
en 19 días uno puede poner una
aplicación subirla a la nube y levantar
50 millones de usuarios
ahora imagínense que los banqueros ante
la inminente llegada de uno de estos
gigantes tecnológicos se ponen todos de
acuerdo y dicen vamos a crear una
aplicación multi banco y vamos a
competir contra estos gigantes
tecnológicos
y en ese proceso de discusiones y de
desarrollo la pide contratos etcétera
tardan dos años en ponerse acuerdo
creen ustedes que es posible que en
cuatro meses entre un gigante como no
van y se lleven todos sus clientes si no
creen que sea posible veamos el
siguiente ejemplo ven mou es una empresa
fintech que nació como una red social de
medios de pago en eeuu empezó a crecer
con tal aceleración que los banqueros
decidieron ponerle un freno y ponerle la
competencia y fundaron un shell shell
fue fundada por bank of america
ricky morgan k pero wang citibank wells
fargo lluís bank y varios otros pero
solo en estos seis bancos están
concentrados más del 80% de los activos
financieros de los estados unidos y sin
embargo hoy día ven no tiene el 45% del
mercado una empresa contra todos esos
bancos 55 por ciento cuál es la clave
del éxito de nuevo time to market
los banqueros no pueden pretender que
sus clientes sigan yendo a sus páginas
web y que bajen sus aplicaciones los
clientes los clientes no quieren hacer
esto mis hijos no saben dicen que las
páginas de internet son para dinosaurios
no saben utilizar o no les gusta usar el
correo electrónico se comunican de otra
forma y no quieren bajar sus
aplicaciones en sus dispositivos móviles
porque les quita espacio para juegos
fotos y vídeos
los clientes están aquí en todas estas
redes sociales y para los banqueros es
realmente sencillo
llegarle a estos clientes y desarrollar
infraestructura tecnológica que les
permita acercarse y hasta darle servicio
a través de estas estas de estas redes
sociales
el corredor de promesas más grande del
mundo está entre eeuu y méxico y
centroamérica y es de 36.5 35.6 billones
de dólares anuales si tomamos en cuenta
que hay 700 millones de iphones en el
mundo y que apoyo a marzo de este año
tenía 245 millones de dólares en cash
qué tan difícil creen ustedes que es
para tomar una parte de ese caso poner
de un botoncito que hoy ya existe de
todos modos y adueñarse del mercado de
remesas entre mexico entre eeuu y
nuestros países es realmente sencillo de
un punto de vista tecnológico
ahora veamos el ejemplo de facebook
en facebook tiene más de 25 patentes
inscritas relacionadas con medios de
pago patentes y permisos y acaba de
anunciar que va a lanzar su cripto
moneda que se llama libra
estas son algunas de las empresas que
están apoyando esta iniciativa y aquí
vemos a visa mastercard astray coin veis
paypal y lo más increíble no vemos a
ningún banco ni siquiera interesado o
viendo qué es lo que está pasando con
esta con esta cripto moneda pero además
si tomamos en cuenta que ya y morgan en
el banco más grande del mundo a
diciembre del año 2018 y tenía dos mil
838 mil millones de dólares en activos y
tenía 100 millones de clientes
pero facebook tiene
y 1.587
millones de usuarios si cada uno de
estos usuarios decide comprar
libras y cargar su cuenta con cinco
dólares para usarla en el marketplace
solo cinco dólares en cuestión de un día
facebook podría convertirse en el banco
más grande del mundo medido por activos
pasivos como ustedes quieran en un día
debemos construir puentes entre bancos y
empresas fintech
yo creo que se ha hecho bien la tarea
pero no se ha hecho con la suficiente
velocidad los bancos no pueden darse el
lujo de tardar dos años en sacar una
aplicación o hacer una mejora a sus
sistemas
los bancos tienen que aprender de las
lecciones de empresas como blackberry
como bars en novo y como blockbuster
pero también tienen que aprender de
empresas o de bancos como bbva que fue
pionero en open banking que fue de los
primeros que abrió su plataforma de apis
a los desarrolladores en menos de seis
meses tenía más de 600 desarrolladores
construyendo sobre sus sistemas
hoy día vivimos en una época en la que
es más importante llegar temprano que
llegar
gracias
[Música]